souvent ce que je constate c'est que ce
sont les les garçons les hommes qui sont
extrêmement quand ils sont malades c'est
un
supportez pas l'être malade mais en
général les filles elles supportent
tu les vois et moi à chaque fois je suis
je suis insupportable et vous revenez
des petits garçons vous avez besoin
qu'on vous coupe
les femmes elles ont une mission elles
savent très bien que la plupart des
femmes quand elles rentrent du travail
le travail n'est pas fini il faut aller
en cours ça s'occuper du gamin
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'on travaille on est des
champions du monde dès qu'on sort du
travail je suis malade
[Musique]
c'est pas un peu sexiste
je me demandais où il voulait en venir
exactement
on s'est
regardé mais non c'est vrai qu'en fait
les femmes historiquement
dans la douleur faut souffrir pour être
belle et donc le rapport des femmes à la
souffrance est plus compliqué on va
moins chez le médecin on s'exprime moins
quand on a mal on nous apprend à prendre
sur nous et peut-être que les hommes ont
vous apprend un petit peu moins à
prendre sur vous manifestement
c'est dans la Bible Dieu il avait dit à
l'homme toi tu travailleras toute ta vie
pour gagner le pain de la famille et à
la femme toi tu accoucheras dans la
douleur ce qu'il avait pas dit à la
femme c'est qu'après non seulement
l'accoucherait dans la douleur mais elle
dirait bosser aussi
là il y a une petite un petit mensonge
féministe vous avez remarqué qu'il y
avait un invité
s
moi je fais un truc qui me semble
essentiel je rince mon nez chaque matin
chaque soir avec de l'eau de mer c'est
le filtre c'est par là que rentre tout
les virus et microbes les machins et je
ne tombe jamais malade est-ce que ce
serait vous aussi le conseil que vous
donneriez ce qui nous écoutent de se
rincer le filtre vas-y est-ce qu'on
doute comme conseil aux enfants en
l'occurrence quand un enfant et qu'il a
une rhinopharyngite ou une infection ORL
première chose qu'on va demander va
demander aux parents c'est de lui rincer
le nez de exactement une chose ben merci
monsieur
avec plaisir
et on a un bonbon contact
c'est un peu urgent un petit chat dans
la gorge donc
oui
docteur s'il vous plaît est-ce qu'on
peut parler en ce moment de risque plus
important que il y a trois quatre
semaines que là on a l'impression que
tout le monde tombe malade j'ai déjà pas
quelqu'un il est malade il s'appelle pas
quelqu'un il est malade dans une période
dans lequel classiquement on se retrouve
avec les infections hivernales donc on a
en ce moment de la rhinopharyngite on a
un début de syndrome ripple on a
évidemment du covid mais on est on est
dans dans ce qui est classique et normal
à cette peur de l’année c'est pas plus
que d'habitude non ah ouais non rien on
a eu alors en ce moment on a énormément
de gens malades mais
les infections liées au covid on en
avait on avait tendance à avoir un peu
plus en ville au plutôt au mois
d'octobre que maintenant c'est à dire
que là vraiment on a la Rhino on a des
débuts de syndrome repos on a de la
bronchiolite chez les enfants mais ça
reste classique pour une période dans
laquelle et on a l'impression d'être au
cours on a déjà
alors justement j'ai une petite question
à vous poser moi je vais la regarder en
dessous j'ai toujours ça c'est du gel il
a il s'appelle Lila délicat donc il faut
se laver les mains mais vous le faites
moi qui a une époque il est
systématiquement comme ça est-ce que
c'est vrai que c'est vrai ça
absolument pas mais mais restons
responsable il suffit de se laver les
morts avec de l'eau et du savon alors
est-ce qu'on peut amener une bassine
pour vous sur le plateau je suis
d'accord mais pour pour les
téléspectateurs qui fonctionnent
normalement l'objet c'est l'eau et le
savon et là c'est absolument pas
agressif pour la peau et donc ça c'est
le premier geste c'est vraiment le
premier geste oui fait partie des gestes
barrières puisque tout vient des mains
vous les mettez partout et après bah
vous les mettez partout c'est vrai c'est
vrai que tous les microbes et tout c'est
un chien viennent au bout des doigts
quoi en fait quand tu as un bébé tu vois
un bébé d'un copain du haut il est
mignon tu lui fais ça
tu lui transmets mille fois plus que
c'est bien embrasse pour le bébé surtout
la mer vous laisse pas faire ok
toi tu dégages
le 2e geste et ça alors ça va ça va en
faire bondir certains vous dites portez
un masque alors je trouve que c'est
extrêmement important de porter un
masque attendez Jean-Marie attendez mais
de qui
pour les gens qui sont malades je le dis
à toute la journée les passions je vois
des passions qui arrivent au cabinet et
qui ont une nez qui coule et qui tousse
ils ont pas de masque au moins que ceux
qui sont malades portent un masque de
manière à ce qu'on se protège les gens
qui sont pas malades ça me semble simple
on n'est pas du tout sur une obligation
totale et complète mais pour que les
gens malades portent un masque comment
on faisait avant pendant des années on
était malade on n'était pas dans le
coeur
et pourquoi maintenant il faut mettre
des masques pendant des années on a les
cheveux
je veux dire c'est pas parce qu'on a
fait mal quelque chose pendant des
années qu'on peut pas changer
il y a encore plus d'enfants malades
est-ce que c'est pas le masque qui nous
a enlevé certains anticorps alors c'est
un débat c'est un débat qui qui a pas
d'intérêt c'est à dire que c'est à dire
que effectivement le fait de porter de
porter en masque a fait que on a on n'a
pas été soumis et contrat à certains
anticorps et donc on va développer une
maladie ok mais l'objet c'est la
population c'est à dire que là on est en
train de protéger des gens quelqu'un qui
est malade on a appris après 2 ans et
demi de deux ans de confinement 4 ou 5
confinement on a appris qu'il fallait
porter un masque quand on est malade on
dit pas de porter un masque pour les
gens qui vont bien qui ont pas de
symptômes mais ceux qui ont des
symptômes portaient un masque ça me
paraît d'une logique absolue en fait
l'objet c'est travailler logiquement
quoi troisième règle avoir une
alimentation équilibrée et oui pourquoi
c'est important parce que c'est quoi
équilibrer ça veut dire quoi on peut
manger
diverses pizza burger burger mais non
mais vous avez vous allez répondre à la
question que vous posez bien évidemment
il faut manger équilibré c'est des seins
c'est ce que dit les messages classiques
c'est cinq fruits et légumes par jour
manger manger sainement et et voilà mais
s'il n'y a pas besoin voilà pardon
il faut boire contre je sais pas
pourquoi il faut voir deux non mais bah
en revanche il faut boire de l'eau
exactement voilà de l'eau vous ne dites
faut boire au moins au moins 2 litres
d'eau par jour je sais pas si vous voyez
la quantité de Ricard que ça représente
[Applaudissements]
chez moi c'est plutôt le chez moi c'est
plutôt le pastis ah oui d'accord ok
alors est-ce que c'est vrai qu'on peut
manger plus en hiver et est-ce que la
raclette c'est considéré comme un plat
équilibré alors on a tendance à tous
manger plus en hiver parce qu'on a froid
et donc à partir du moment où on affront
on va manger un peu plus donc les deux
trois kilos vous allez prendre l'hiver
vous allez perdre l'été la raquette
est-ce que c'est un plat équilibré non
si c'est une fois dans l'hiver pourquoi
pas l'objet c'est de se faire plaisir
aussi il faut rester quelque chose de
logique on se fait plaisir le problème
des trois kilos de l'hiver tu les perds
pas l'hiver d'après tu en prends trois
de plus et chaque hiver
alors quatrième conseil bien aéré le
domicile
pour aérer le matin ça dépend de la
température extérieure une heure avant
12h et puis il faut faire des économies
tous les matins sont son appartement et
son logement c'est une bonne chose à
faire ce qu'on va renouveler l'air à
l'intérieur même s'il y a des aérateurs
qui sont intégrés dans les fenêtres on
va renouveler l'air et donc c'est
extrêmement important
[Rires]
qui viennent de tomber
Pôle emploi
et hier soir parce qu'il y avait du
rouge à lèvres sur ta chemise mais
docteur à propos de l'aération est-ce
qu'on parle du 19 degrés à la maison
est-ce qu'on tombe moins malade quand il
fait froid chez soi est-ce que c'est
mieux en fait par rapport à l'hiver
c'est lié à la consommation d'énergie il
y a pas d'éléments
l'appartement super chaud super froid
c'est pas bon donc restons logique il
faut qu'il fasse suffisamment bon pour
pouvoir vivre à l'intérieur 19 degrés si
vous portez un pull on y arrive voilà
mais la mesure à 19 degrés elle est pas
liée à un problème de santé publique ou
un problème de santé tout court elle est
dit un problème de consommation
énergétique donc faut pas voilà ce que
dormir nu c'est bien ça dépend avec qui
bravo
non non
vous savez comment on fait pour congeler
une morue
[Rires]
c'est le truc d'avant ah bon bah oui ah
le morue tu vois d'accord
[Rires]
je fais vérifier mon lit toutes les
semaines parce que vous aviez peur des
bêtes et des acariens je vais vérifier
ah ouais voilà mais qui vérifie
exactement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais avec un drap ou Sandra même le
lit offert
de la mousse
à 19 degrés oui je peux vous dire
[Rires]
faire de l'activité sportive ça c'est
très important c'est indispensable une
bête indispensable d'abord parce que ça
va ça va vous permettre de vous sentir
beaucoup mieux vous allez libérer des
endorphines donc vous aurez voilà un peu
comme série d'endorphines parce que il
est jamais malade donc ça va libérer des
endorphines et surtout ça va stimuler
l'immunité bien sûr donc c'est très très
important de continuer à enfin d'avoir
une activité sportive y compris en hiver
voilà donc c'est le moment le plus
compliqué pour le faire un peu froid
dehors qui fait du sport ici
bon ben je vais arrêter d'en faire
[Rires]
en ce moment non j'ai arrêté
très sportive merci en tout cas très
beau témoignage